admit it when it comes to food we all
have weird combos that we love to
indulge in
no matter how gross it may sound to
others
my niece sadie kargman says don't yuck
my yum
hashtag don't yuck my yum and our next
guest is no stranger to weird food
combos
he has more than a million followers on
tick tock who love to watch him cook
including me and my daughters take a
look pickles and peanut butter
nasty mayo with jelly sandwich there's
no way this is edible
you could have paid me billy dollars to
eat that
please welcome 18 year old social media
superstar
ayton burnham hi
good morning perhaps my first ever talk
show appearance
oh a ton we love you so much i mean
my girls and i are such huge fans of
yours
how did you start on tick tock
well i have always loved food and
cooking ever since i remember and around
the age of 11 i competed on the first
ever kids episode of chopped
and that really turned my passion for
cooking into my career i started
instagram page
food blog but really changed the game
was in november of 2019
i started my tick tock page and i made a
bet with my teacher that i can get over
a million views on the platform by the
end of the school year and i did it four
hours later with a video in my school
cafeteria
and here we are today well we love
watching you watch we love watching you
try weird food combos
and um i thought that we could try some
of these
and uh stryker our producer came up with
a really fun idea
because these are some celebrity faves
that have gone viral
so you want to try them let's start off
honestly i'm dreading this one this is
the thing i don't like tuna to begin
with
and this is from adrienne by lone hewton
who posted a video on youtube
where she claimed this is her favorite
food where not only does she mix
mix it into the tuna but she then dips
the entire sandwich into fruit punch
not not excited for this one sadie
kargman don't yuck my yum
okay oh you know what all my tuna fell
out i can't have that all right so are
we dipping
this i'm not excited okay
oh my god
[Laughter]
good thing we have a spit bucket isn't
this a nice one too oh that is
i think we just yucked her young oh my
god i did i think we did yuck her yum i
feel
terrible but that that was weird okay
what's our new
next food come on that was quite the
experience we got through it next up i'm
honestly pretty excited for this one
this one comes from scott foley's
instagram he posted a
video of him and his son eating this for
breakfast and he claims it's a family
thing
that adds more protein to breakfast i'm
not gonna lie i feel like this one could
work i am not gonna lie
i love eggs and peanut butter and i'm
kind of really scared
all right here we go ready
okay that works it definitely works yeah
oh my god this is making me think you
could put peanut butter on a shoe and
it's delicious
thank you stop fully all right what's
our last combo
the last one comes from jennifer
lawrence now this is a double whammy it
is a weird food combo
within another weird food combo she
likes to take chili that has noodles in
it which sounds like a weird food combo
to me
and it's as if that wasn't enough
sandwich it between two slices of pizza
all right i i'm not gonna lie i'm really
excited for this one
cheers let's go
oh there's a lot back
[Laughter]
it's interesting
yeah it's like
how do you describe it is uh
it was i'm getting like italian oregano
and then like
kind of an american lot and like
silly thing it it feels like kind of
it it doesn't mesh like it's like two
distinct flavors battling it out but i
like
both of them yeah i feel like if we just
separate them and eat them separate
it'll be delicious
like literally what i want to do is do
that like this
yeah i'm with you i love your kitchen um
you built that yourself didn't you i did
we're actually it's actually in my
garage it's where i film my videos and
i've designed it and built it out myself
thank you i love
it kind of delicious not gonna lie
yeah the chili spaghetti
is amazing in fact there's a restaurant
called bob's big boy
in los angeles where they're famous for
their chili spaghetti so
yeah i might start adding spaghetti into
my chili
eton you are literally our hero would
you honor honor us
with your presents again and please come
back to the show cause we love you
of course anytime thank you so much for
having me this was super fun and maybe
one time we can cook or eat some more
weird food combos
um let's do it asap
because i need to hang out with you all
the time eitan thank you so much all
right
if anybody's watching at home and you
want to tweet us your favorite unique
weird food concoction then use the
hashtag drew's food combos
and we might try them on the show with
[Music]
aton
you